we're on slack we're on zoom we're
connecting to employees around the world
even frontline workers are taking
opportunities that are outside of their
day-to-day experience and so the
fundamental truth is that the way work
is done is different the way we as
individuals think about ourselves right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with rusland of
bulatov vice president of global
marketing at gloat the world's first
ai-powered talent marketplace platform
in his role ruslan oversees a global
team of marketers across brand demand
product marketing and content bringing
the globe story to the world's largest
enterprises prior to gloat ruslan has
storied career across products
partnerships research and marketing at
companies including thrive global google
youtube and contour retail he has a 30
under 30 recognized creative a native
russian speaker and a proud dartmouth
grad currently based in new york
city ruslan bulatov welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm doing really well thanks for having
me
thank you very very much for being here
with me vice president of global
marketing at gloat
so really really important position and
a really important company today the
world is changing talent is changing
things are moving quicker people are
looking for new opportunities and and
it's a it's a fascinating time to be
alive and to be an employee and to to
have a talent of some sort and and we
have gloat that is helping enterprises
move like startups i love that statement
from your website and i can only imagine
the fascinating position you're in as
vice president of global marketing in
this company so welcome
thank you so much it's a true pleasure
being here
thank you
before we get started to talk about
gloat and talk about you know this
global marketplace for talent tell me a
little bit about your own journey and
you know you've held some quite
fascinating positions you know within uh
google youtube
within thrive and some other
organizations as well
you know where how do you see your own
career as you go through your journey
i've been really blessed by a
fascinating career journey so i was born
in moscow russia
and moved to the united states at a very
young age
and
started my career actually in the states
at a company called cantar retail and
kantar for those that don't know does
large-scale consumer research really
helps some of the largest at that time
some of the large cpg companies and some
of the largest manufacturers make
decisions around what products to create
how to price package et cetera and all
that was rooted in large-scale consumer
understanding where we do ethnography
shop alongs in
large scale surveys and that really set
me up for the rest of my career in many
ways because it taught me the power of
consumer insights it taught me the power
of human decision making
and so i had an interesting story going
into google where i got recruited had a
funny story which we may get into where
i thought the recruiter was actually not
even real because they signed it with
the funny google letters ignored the
recruiter but uh found my way going into
google um and having an amazing journey
there for almost about seven years even
eight um where i worked on the the core
google business and mobile uh which we
might get into
um i really picked up the ins and outs
of marketing there and and the future of
digital and storytelling because we went
from you know traditional search to
display and mobile um the to
programmatic advertising and then to
youtube and where i spent the the better
part of my career we launched an amazing
special team there called the brand lab
where we worked with 250 of the the
largest brands over the course of five
years helping them move to digital in
their branded storytelling incredible
and then uh found myself lucky enough to
get recruited into a tiny company called
thrive global at a time when
not everyone was talking about mental
health and well-being but i saw
something in what the ceo ariana
huffington was trying to do with the
business and she had just written a book
called thrive that uh really spoke to me
and it was all about this question
around you know we were all obsessed
with technology but what about the human
human side of things what about humanity
and we built a business out of it we
turned it into a sas business uh grew it
you know from the ground up i was an
employee like 15 there 16.
and spent four great years there and
then found myself at gloat um now gloat
is transforming as we'll get into the
the conversation around how we match
talent opportunities how we think about
careers how we think about data-driven
decision-making around talent within
organizations how do we make
organizations more agile
and so i've had uh you know an
interesting journey they kind of built
one on top of the other but i'm very
happy to be you know sharing some of
that with you today
so ruslan i already am apologizing
because i'm going to go fast because
there's way too much information i want
to pack in these a very short 20 minutes
that we have in this in this episode so
okay first of all brain the brain lab
you know the brand lab not well it's
also a brain lab but the brand lab
you're looking at 250 brands across the
world you're you're leading it on a
global level you know within google and
youtube what is that like what do you
learn about creating a sustainable brand
in the digital world digitalizing brands
for consumers yeah you're absolutely
right we could talk for hours just about
that topic i think that was one of the
most fundamental experiences for me
because
you got to understand the decision
making that organizations have been
doing for you know decades around brand
building and how do you actually adapt
that to new channels and new mediums and
it was actually very interesting because
that when we launched brand was 2012
very hard to imagine but at that time
youtube was just a place for dogs and
cats on skates boards it was not a place
to build brands right it was funny
videos of babies and pets and there was
no facebook video there's no instagram
video that let alone tick tock and so it
was crazy to imagine like when you hard
to imagine a world
it's absolutely insane how quickly
things change so our our conversations
were actually if you had a video
recording you'd be almost appalled
because it's like how could you not see
the power of digital video how could you
not see the power of going beyond a 15
or 30 second spot and beyond just
measuring success in terms of gross
rating points on television at that time
people didn't even believe that we were
going to move to digital right netflix
was not a thing yet in the way that it
is today
so it was a a lot of the lessons learned
there was how do you actually shift
people's mindsets and expose them to
actually new thinking new opportunities
and inspire them to try new things even
though they've been doing something the
same way for 20 30 years
right i think that you know i can only
imagine the excitement of of working
with these brands and and iterating on
this process of creativity and figuring
out how how do how does consumer
behavior change around the world and how
are we positioned to help these brands
you know as such a big enterprise now
your entrance to thrive you know working
with huffington you know you mentioned
the 15th employee yes i was 15th or 16th
yes on
unbelievable you know a company that i
think has over a thousand employees by
now
and you know with such an important
mission and then becoming chief
marketing officer what what are what are
just a few you know key moments or
lessons that you've learned you know as
you grow your own marketing
understanding and capacity now at a
startup not at a big enterprise that you
were before yeah it was it you know i
actually get calls from googlers like
that all the time to this day you know
how do you make that shift because you
know even to this day you know the
company is doing incredibly well but uh
people want to take risks and chances
and it really is a different journey and
i think one of the number one lessons if
anyone's listening that isn't come going
from a larger company or deciding
between the two is
you know the the grind is very real in a
startup environment when you're a small
company and in that in that sense then
there isn't someone kind of that you can
you know i always joked at google you
could file a ticket for something and it
would just get to get taken care of
there's uh but you know ariana literally
joked with us when we started the
company i remember coming into the first
office she was like listen if the trash
doesn't get taken out i take out the
trash and she picked up you know the
trash can and she started walking
towards the door and that mentality
actually really carries i think a lot of
successful
entrepreneurs i think it carries a lot
of successful people that join startups
where you can't just sit back and expect
someone else to do something or someone
else to take care of it one of our
culture values at gloat here today is
get it done it's actually our number one
value and it's this idea you don't sit
back and wait for it to get done you
just get it done and that mentality i
think is very important it's one of the
biggest things i can tell you know
probably 100 stories that i learned
along the way but i think that one has
to underpin everything that you do
um and then the other thing on the
mental health and well-being space is
just
i think it's so important to to realize
that a lot of times when you're working
at a startup you know you're kind of
creating the market
and not everyone is going to see it at
first you know it took us a while when
we were starting that and why it was
such an honor to be
cmo of that business is
we were trying to convince the world
that mental health and well-being
mattered you know you would walk into a
room and people would almost want to
laugh you out being like ah this is soft
things you know these are soft crap
and but you have to really believe in in
what you're doing and that's why having
the right people around you having the
right leadership team
is very important because there are very
hard days where you question like is
this ever going to get adopted are
people ever going to realize this or are
we crazy
but if you really have to believe in
what you're doing and that was true it
thrived for us on mental health and
well-being and now you know you can't
walk into a business conversation
without talking about employee
well-being or mental health
and the world is fundamentally changed
and we find the same thing at gloat now
right where we're pushing the boundaries
on how we think about talent on how we
think about skills and how we think
about opportunities on how we think
about hierarchies within organizations
and there are a lot of people that are
afraid of that change almost like what i
said about brand lab people have been
doing the same thing for 20 30 years why
disrupt and so being able to get things
done and also really stay committed and
believe in that what you're doing is
right and meaningful and there's a
reason you get up every day and
surrounding yourself with the right
people that push you along i think those
were two of the best kind of the biggest
realizations i had moving from a large
enterprise to a smaller team
incredible so connecting the dots
between your work with huffington at
thrive and being the chief marketing
officer there changing consumer behavior
you know one probably the most exciting
thing anybody can ask to do at a c-level
position in a company uh growing
growing the way that that the company
thrive grew and now doing it at gloat
also shifting consumer behavior the
world is changing you know perhaps um
very similar to how the world shifted
also organically to understanding that
mental health is such an important
concept
you still have that responsibility on
your shoulders as as chief marketing
officer now we're looking at talent and
we're looking at the global talent
marketplace and we're looking at you
know helping enterprises move with
agility and realizing that hiring is not
just about you know the contract it's
actually about
it's actually about you know aligning
the talent to the needs and share with
me a little bit about gloat first as a
company and then how your work at gloat
is complementary to sort of the journey
that you've been on until now yeah and i
think it's worth mentioning you know
because some of your listeners will
probably be in in israel you know
there's a there's a side of globe that a
lot of you know um
locally that um is
the external side where we actually
match external talent opportunities at
any company but where we really hit
the aha moment where we clicked into
hyper growth is something we built
called the talent marketplace and the
idea is simple but it's incredibly
disruptive and this is what we're
actually bringing to companies around
the world in emea america and all around
the globe and it's this idea that
imagine instead of your employees
thinking their next best opportunity is
outside of the company
looking internally it's actually inside
and um it's you know it's such a simple
idea but it's a fundamental shift in the
way we think about talent and and up
matching people to opportunities and
careers and everything and the reason
it's so disruptive is because of the way
we execute it right for so long kind of
what i was saying about the 20 30 years
of of talent management maybe even
longer actually it's 100 years we've
traced it back to the original org chart
if you look back to the original org
chart
of ibm 100 years ago it is literally you
know an executive at the top and then
directors and then people in boxes kind
of trickling down
and the reality is that that's not how
work is done anymore we're not just
looking at an org chart and saying oh
this is my place in there let me do a
command and cut like and control style
way of managing the business managing
work we're on slack we're on zoom we're
connecting to employees around the world
even frontline workers are taking
opportunities that are outside of their
day-to-day experience and so the
fundamental truth is that the way work
is done is different the way we as
individuals think about ourselves right
you think about the macro trends we
don't believe we're just one title or
one job or one thing we have side gigs
side hustles we will have hobbies and we
care about that we try to bring that
into work podcasts
and the reality is we didn't have a
mechanism for talent management that way
so the talent marketplace actually
breaks down skills of people and their
passions on one side and then breaks
down work on the other and dynamically
connects the two it decentralizes the
decision making this isn't about hr
saying okay let's go through the formal
review process and decide that this is
the head count that you will get
allocated for the next year or two years
you want to post a project you're
launching a new ice cream brand
somewhere you can pull together a team
you're going on maternity leave you can
break out your roll into five six rolls
and have people backfill
both true stories one from unilever
launched an ice cream brand in six weeks
instead of months and months um all from
assembling a team around the globe
another one from schneider electric
where you know someone was going on
maternity leave backfilled her role and
then what happened she came back to her
role
avoiding the drama figuring out where
does the person go in the organization
and then ended up promoting one or two
people that that worked on her in her
position because she saw that they were
actually capable of stepping up
so i have hundreds of these types of
stories we're working with some of the
largest brands in the world
um and we have you know an incredible
set of stories just like that that
companies are really starting to think
is is there a new way to manage talent
and work in the organization it's all
powered by this idea of a talent
marketplace
beautiful now obviously i can see you
sitting now with the ceos and the and
the c-level execs of these large
companies and making that case and
everybody completely understands your
your point of view but let's talk about
the mid that you know the mid-level
managers the the team leaders the even
the vps you know you have to really
educate an organization into even having
people think
that maybe before we actually go
externally to look at different
opportunities let's look internally
right this is you know both top down and
bottom up so how do you get your message
to the remaining portion of the
organization that may not be at the same
strategic level of thinking that the
c-level exists are spending days in and
days out i think that's where our job
becomes really exciting you know i like
a good marketing challenge um and i
think the the beauty of us working with
some of these large enterprises you said
something very astute you use the word i
think kind of a changing consumer
mindset and i actually think that way
all the time about the way i think about
enterprise
marketing and enterprise storytelling
because it's never just about the
business it's equally about the end
users of that business and employees and
so when we tell that story you're
absolutely right right selling in
enterprise software the technology is
step one sometimes it's actually the
easier step um and the the how do you
get people to adopt it how do you get
people to actually change their
behaviors and managers in this case are
a huge component of that because we have
been taught for so long
to really hold our head count as a
sacred number oh i got this headcount
i'm not letting that go but the magic
that happens and this is you know my job
then as a marketer is to
find these stories and then bring them
to the people within these organizations
and the market
you know that idea is called talent
hoarding and the reality is it's a fear
that never gets realized
time and time again every customer that
rolls out of town marketplace what they
find and their managers find is that
when you open up your talent
you actually get access to even more
talent
because if you're working on interesting
things if you're a good manager if
you're if you're actually
you know working on something that is
worthy of attention you can get all of a
sudden
access to a talent pool that you never
had before so
all of a sudden managers are realizing
wait yeah i gave up a few hours of my
teammates time or my co-workers time to
something but now i actually have access
to talent i never had before and i'll
give you one quick example we were um
even at ed gloat
i just launched a product a new video
for a product launch we were doing and i
had this idea of saying okay well let me
think about um
if i'm doing this i'll either work with
a creative agency to do this work and
i'll get someone to do the voice over or
we'll hire a voice over artist
and i had this realization we call it we
glowed internally i said what if i post
that project what if i ask for a
voiceover artist internally i kid you
not within about an hour or two
someone from our customer success team
says hey by the way i am a professional
voiceover artist for brands you might
recognize like the home depot in the us
and jack daniels whiskey
sends me the most beautiful pristine
recordings as a professional studio at
home we had a custom recording done from
within the company so now what is that
manager of that the that employee see
they have an engaged employee who's now
taking on a marketing project having fun
hopefully um seems like he had fun but
he's now actually representing the brand
in even bigger way he's part of
something special that's beyond just a
day-to-day and so that manager now sees
someone that's actually a bigger part of
the tapestry of the company so you know
again i could share hours of stories
like that both from within glo and of
course the many companies that we're
working with like unilever and nestle
and schneider electric and seagate and
mastercard and you name them but it's a
really it's an important shift in the
way we think about talent and work and
so my job as a marketing leader is
really letting the customers and the
employees frankly tell that story for us
i think one of the most interesting
things that you know one day will
probably be studied in business schools
as well as the sort of the ripple effect
and what this does not i think and you
touched on you started touching this a
little bit you're talking about you know
you know creating an engaged employee
and and you know i think that you know
one of the consumer shifts it's not just
understanding that employees have
multiple talents for multiple parts of
the organization but it's also the fact
that if you empower employees to to work
on another part of the organization
you're not missing out on their work
within your team you're empowering them
to engage more with your brand and
they're going to be more committed to
your team because they want to stay
longer and they want to to leverage
their talent in in various ways and i
think that that is going to be an
interesting and interesting idea to see
whether it's something that's
quantifiable or just something that we
are able to measure and to see how we
can actually find the right balance
between all those pieces and i think
that what you're doing with globe is
fascinating obviously the journey that
you've that you've had with thrive and
with google and youtube and your company
i think it's it's really fascinating and
and i really want to thank you for these
20 minutes but but i want to get to know
ruslan just a little bit better take me
back before starting your company before
you know doing marketing you know 10
years old elementary school middle
school somewhere around that time what
are you fascinated by what really sparks
your curiosity yeah it's uh i love that
question so uh and as you're asking i
think i went to two different places i
think one
you know i was such a child of the the
transition between moscow and and and
america and so i became so hungry to
understand cultural differences and i
think they've always been really driven
by that and cultural differences to me
you know they meant so many different
things it was from the t the things that
were on tv like i remember growing up
and in a way feeling like i was getting
all my morals from a show called the
fresh prince of bel air which of course
a lot of people know with will smith and
and family matters um and just and just
being kind of this culture
transformation of you know understanding
different nuances what drives people
cultural backgrounds the different
experiences that people have
that was always fascinating to me and
then i think where
the the next experience that i think was
really fundamental to me was
i'm just i was always fascinated by
consumer mindset i think there was a
story that i've told in interviews
before and i still think about all the
time i remember walking into the
checkout aisle or walking to a grocery
store getting to the checkout aisle and
seeing a new brand of gum
in the shelf and it was i think the
stride gum that it was it was a little
later i think it was probably in
middle school or high school
and i remember looking at the back of
this and it was a new package it had
like a little portfolio it looked like a
little briefcase almost you like slotted
in as had this cool little tin foil
on the cover and i was very interested
by and said um
and then i looked look i turned it and
it said wrigley's on it i was like wait
a minute wrigley's makes juicy fruit and
all these other brands and then i
started turning them around and
realizing wrigley's makes a lot of these
gum brands and i started realizing like
wait there's this
decision-making process that this gum is
worth this much on the shelf and uses
this color and is in this format versus
stride versus five versus you name the
different types of gums on the on the
market
and it kind of was it blew my mind this
idea that
um you have to really think about
positioning pricing packaging
aligning that to consumer expectations
and needs and i think that actually got
me on this journey to where i am today
with you know leading marketing teams
and and trying to connect the the
business opportunities and product the
right products to the right people in
the consumer mindset
fascinating that's that's all i can say
it's just fascinating
thank you so so much for these 20
minutes thank you for the amazing work
and that you've been doing you know both
in google youtube mental health with
thrive now with gloat and transforming
you know really the lives of employees
and organizations a ripple effect that
will that will impact uh both on a
business level but also on the cultural
level on a personal level so thank you
for for your time and your energy and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you michael you're inspiring many
of us i love the conversations you've
had i've listened to many of them i
think you're you're putting a lot of
great wisdom into the market and i take
great inspiration from it so thank you
for
hosting this and bringing wisdom to the
world
[Music]